we will now go through another example
to consolidate our intuition about the
content of the law of iterated
expectations and the law of the total
variance the example is as follows we
have a class and that class consists of
30 students in total who are divided in
two sections the first and the second
section let X I be the score of student
I let's say the final grade in the class
we consider the following probabilistic
experiment we pick a student at random
uniformly so that each student is
equally likely to be picked and we
define two random variables X is a
numerical random variable that gives us
the score of the selected student so if
student I is selected the value of the
random variable capital X is X I and
capital y is defined as the random
variable which is the section of the
selected student so that Y takes values
1 or 2 we are given some information for
the first section the average of the
students scores is 94 the second section
the average of the students course is 60
given that information what is the
expected value of the students score
well each student is equally likely to
be picked
so has probability 1 over 30 to be
picked and this multiplies the score of
the student so this is the expected
value of the random variable of interest
what is this number well we need to
calculate the sum of the X is the sum of
the first ten x i's is equal to 90 times
10 and the sum of the x i's in the other
section is equal to 60 times 20 and we
carry out the calculation and we find
that the answer is 70 now let us look at
conditional expectations if Y is equal
to 1 this means that the student from
section 1 was picked and within that
section each student
is equally likely to be picked so the
outcome of this random variable is
equally likely to be any one of these X
eyes each X I get speaks with
probability one over ten and so the
expected value of this random variable
is ninety similarly for the second
section the expected value of the score
of a randomly selected student given
that the student belongs in that section
is equal to sixty with this information
available now we can describe the
abstract conditional expectation which
is a random variable this random
variable takes the value of ninety if a
student from the first section was
picked and the value of sixty if a
student from the second section was
picked what is the probability of this
event that the student from the first
section was picked given that the first
section has ten out of a total of thirty
students this probability is one-third
and therefore this probability is
two-thirds now that we have the
distribution of this random variable we
can calculate the expected value of this
random variable which is one-third times
ninety plus two-thirds times 60 and this
number evaluates to seventy which of
course it's no coincidence is the same
as the average over the entire class by
the law of iterated expectations we know
that this quantity should be the same as
this quantity so the law of iterated
expectations allows us to calculate the
overall average in the entire class by
taking the section averages and weigh
them according to the sizes of the
different sections
it's a divide-and-conquer method and it
is similar to what we have been doing
when we use the total expectation
theorem to divide and conquer we
continue with our example and here is a
summary of what we found so far the
conditional expectation is a random
variable that takes these two values
with certain probabilities and the mean
of this random variable
is equal to 70 let us now calculate the
variance of this random variable this
random variable with probability 1/3
takes a value of 90 which is this much
away from the mean of this random
variable which we square and with
probability 2/3 it takes a value of 60
which is this much away from the mean of
the random variable we square this as
well and when we carry out the
calculation we find that this number is
equal to 200 let us now continue and
suppose that somebody gave us this piece
of information for the first section
this is the deviation of the I student
from the mean of that section so this is
the sum of the squares of the deviations
and then we average over all the
students we will use this data to
calculate certain quantities for example
the variance of the scores in the first
section now in the first section with
probability one tenth we pick the I
student that has this score and this is
the deviation of that student from the
mean of that section so this is the same
as the mean squared deviation from the
mean of the section and this is exactly
the variance within that section it is
the variance of the random variable
which is the score of a random student
given that we are selecting a student
from the first section for the second
section the story is similar were given
this information and this tells us the
variance of the students course within
the second section so now we can
describe the abstract conditional
variance it is a random variable that
takes this value with probability equal
to the probability of selecting someone
from this section which is one-third or
it takes a value of 20
which is the variance in the second
section and the second section is
selected with probability 2/3 with this
information at hand now we can calculate
the expected value of this random
variable which is 1/3 times 10 plus 2/3
times 20 which is 50 over 3 at this
point we have the two quantities that
are necessary to apply the law of total
variance according to the law of total
variance the variance of the students
course throughout the entire class is
equal to this number which is 50 over 3
plus this number which is 200 and this
is the overall variance
now let us interpret the law of total
variance in this context the
interpretation is as follows the
variance of the students course in the
entire class consists of two pieces the
first piece looks at the variance inside
each section which is 10 or 20 depending
on which section were looking at and we
take the average over the different
sections so we look at the variability
of the scores within a typical section
and then we average over all the
sections the other term looks at the
means in the different sections and
figures out how different are these
means how much do they vary from the
overall class average it measures the
variability between different sections
so the overall randomness in the test
scores can be broken down into two
pieces of randomness one source of
randomness is that the different
sections have different means the other
source of randomness is that inside each
section the students are different from
means of their section and these two
pieces of randomness together add up to
the total randomness of in the students
course as measured by the variance of
the entire class